Kamala Harris is the least popular vice
president in recent memory I somebody
said that the poll conducted this month
shows 32 percent of registered voters
have a positive view of Kamala Harris
compared with 49 who have a negative
view of her this is a net negative
rating for those of you who are not
mathematically inclined of negative 17
points the lowest for any vice president
in the polls history and if you compare
it with other polls you're looking at at
least the least popular vice president
since 1995 Saint Al Gore this is of
course very bad news for Kamala Harris
really good news for Biden though and
it's not a coincidence I don't think